o ato vem aqui falar um bocadinho sobre
o porto como alvo isso que me inspiravam
duche e onde eu trabalho todos os dias
de facto por causa desse meu andar diabo
lar para o wii
tenho visto algumas coisas a gente tem
feito algumas reflexões
gostava de partilhar convosco nestes
últimos 20 anos tem argumenta assistida
muita coisa desaparecer
e eu acho que nós podemos fazer as
coisas de outra forma
há cerca de 12 anos atrás pediram pra eu
fazer um um estudo que seria a base para
um plano de gestão do centro histórico
do porto que é uma uma ferramenta
obrigatória para quando um edifício onde
mora um imóvel está na lista da unesco é
e eu a estudar estas questões de facto
apercebi me que isto público ramal que
já naquela altura o o ocidente histórica
muito agradável muito difícil
abandonados e e pouca gente a viver lá
de facto estou anunciando história com
esta dimensão é era mas eu sou muito
complicada
o que eu pensei na altura é que o pior
que podia acontecer era um distrito
comprava uma vez para vir aqui se uma
grande empreitada que vai comprar e
fazer grandes obras de renovação
neste centro histórico mas é o que está
acontecendo neste momento o que está
acontecendo neste momento nós todos
temos essa experiência e ver aquilo que
tem que tá acontecendo no governo no
centro histórico e portanto a partir daí
eu aconselhei a atrás ter filhos agora
tenho três filhos já há muitos anos e
portanto para mostrar por que é que este
facto pode não ser assim tão bom porque
eu acho que pode ser uma oportunidade
perdida para a cidade do porto
chegamos assim tanto numa um bem que
deve ser desta mais digamos mais bem
guardado é mais chegado nesse sentido
não tenta a inclusão de mochilas entanto
uma só vez é o pior pode acontecer então
eu vou tentar
falaram carinho sobre estas destas
questões que levam a falar
este não era o próximo faz mas não há
problema
posso começar aqui com a françozo show
em que é uma referência para quem
estudou essas coisas o patrimônio e
facto ela já que há uns anos dizia que
esta resposta reabilitação of fato
trazer uma destruição causando vários
séculos a fazer naturalmente há portanto
é esta sentença são as fotografias que
eu tenho nenhum temperatura que esta foi
aqui há uns anos né
na rua do corpo da guarda é extremamente
tatus gravar mas será que isto é é
melhor que fizemos aqui
todas as casas foram corridas com a
mesma categoria sei lá o quê é com a
mesma cor
todas as casas são pintados na mesma cor
das mesmas chaminés a tinha uma
característica que o importante é a
diversidade de materiais e trabalhos é e
esta é uma homogeneização pode não estar
facto a sair cara outro outro caso que
eu tava aqui é uma coleção que existiu
aqui num muro dos bacalhoeiros na frente
e vai para o portal da cidade é que é um
famoso hotel que está confiante na
posição do hotel
a ampliação do hotel a obrigou a
poluição entre alguns edifícios ficaram
apenas nas cantorias nas fachadas
nós temos resultado não é também outra
vez a mesma coisa
o problema é que não pode é tentam
imitar o que lá estava e oportuno num é
é uma cidade feita por artistas
eu às vezes vou a passearem fica sem
olhar para as praças coisas com por
tanque facto notas uma alma especial a e
e e nós hoje passamos por lá e vermos
facto bondosa dentro de edifícios um
edifício quinhentista neste caso da
ponte nova que faz frente para a rua das
flores
521 esta casa já existia antes disso
portanto o facto nós estamos a destruir
coisas que poderiam ser um valor
acrescentado para a cidade
aí é esse aí há sentimento que eu acho
que nós devemos refletir vai-vai também
camisetas a sair em encontrar uma
maneira quase todos os dias pra ver que
só uma pancada mas a arma do poder tocar
há aqui vários minutos só passar três
dias que tem tirava alimentos que são
removidos para o lixo
eu sou o único souto moura também é
também discutir a questão e estamos a
mulher isto tudo porque não não faz
muito sentido e como eu dizia
de facto os detalhes estão são
importantes
o casal e em grandes designers diziam
isto que o esgoto não não é não é saltar
é mesmo o produto ou são o produto não é
tanto o porto tem esta coisa que é estes
detalhes das das capitanias janelas e e
os azulejos pintados com cores são um
produto especial é uma diversidade que
errar outra cidade tem a outras cidades
em portugal que tem e ainda vai mas é
oportunizar facto está a faltar passar
mal a nós vemos o porto com estas três
filiados e estas clarabóias e e vamos
aproximando e vemos vamos vendo muitos
muitos detalhes interessantes
infelizmente há muita gente que ainda
vão mantendo até vidraça especial uma
vidraça antiga um vidro o filho porque
os caixas não sei lá vizinhas e portanto
essas coisas são importantes mas chama a
atenção para essa cortina da avó a nota
hoje em dia substituindo as cafeterias
porque dizem que a eficiência energética
a estudos recentes dando os carros-chefe
três clubes que esta cortei esta cortina
a vida do povo tá aqui facto não há
necessidade de estarmos a
vamos ver e fazer um investimento enorme
em carteirinhas modernas e depois não
deixou entrar o ar e eu ordem portanto
dificilmente respirarem facto podemos
perder a esperança num sanção não é todo
estas palestras gastaria estão na rua de
são joão eu temo por elas porque já
estão cobertas com uma hora neste
momento e não se encontrar em londres
vão estar lá ainda ou não e facto não
tenho dúvidas que são as cafeterias é
originais do edifício tem é do jornal
ethnos e o alvor no plano do dos tempos
armadas nessa conta são joão em 1763
função é temos temos via já temos portas
em vias de extinção como estas de facto
é são cada vez mais raras e e pormenor
para nós com esta esta suas que também
cada vez que se faz uma obra essas
coisas aparecem
estamos a respeitar vamos respeitar ou
não olha mais este caso trago aqui todas
as flores e espécies entrada free ontem
aumentar com alguma qualidade mas teve
de ser um táxi estava partidas e os
azulejos que para enviar às lojas em
falta e as mas hoje ontem passei por lá
e estao a carteirinha do prédio cor rosa
já são uma imitação
as outras são esta moda que agora está
aqui é uma das teorias manhã mas que
imitam o pvc é que o é igual é muito
grosseiro mas leves novos andré dias
letivos campanha para trás a pobreza foi
a pobreza que permitiu que os nossos
dias intacto não foi foi foi a lei das
rendas foi em 1948 e facto os
proprietários ficaram sem maiores
problemas
fazer a devida manutenção dos seus
imóveis mas facções açores também nossa
straw mais correta outro caso aqui no
bairro são domingos
castries magníficas vejam estas as
carteirinhas a em hangzhou china também
visto em santander espanhol que se faz
uma obra caixa de brita e vai
desaparecendo passavam uns anos puseram
as categorias ainda com um centro médico
e com vidro simples mas lá se foi o arco
e passei também ontem já é este tipo de
caixa seria administração também é isto
nem sequer uma é uma rotina isto é uma
coisa que agora e tem um vidro único
traz duplo pronto eu deixo aqui a nossa
consideração a oportunidade do porto
poderia ter como cidade única com
materiais unicom como as coisas
maravilhosas exóticas eu acho que muitos
dos segredos do porto em termos
jurídicos tutelados ver com essa coisa
de ser exótico é uma cidade mantendo
assim atacar até até o século 21
bom essas categorias a mansão e ela já
marcava vão para o lixo como vemos aqui
é paixão colocadas outras de cariz
industrial tanto a indústria da
construção soube adaptar se vai ouvindo
a durante alguns anos
nos últimos anos as entidades que fazem
esta gestão do centro histórico foram
pedindo castrista em madeira e ainda a
construção de uma caixa da manhã
só que o fato não não tem a mesma israel
teza que estas carteiras antigas facto
são só uma coisa que mais parece o
ártico como diz o nosso mestre ziza a
nossa categoria só que temos a perceção
também portas que são vagas para o lixo
mostras inteiras como neste caso na rua
das flores
eu eu acho que neste momento já não é
uma melhoria já é uma um restaurante
também não cheguei confirmar ganhar mais
um cruzamento da rua das flores
aqui o nosso flash a romã também ficou
tudo de uma só vez sem as suas
carteirinhas todas todas pronto toda a
escola e imaginem neste momento ao
provar isto é isto é os meus amigos
cristal anos dizem não tinham lhes disse
manny
eles ficam assim a olhar próprio das
medidas que estamos a fazer a nós
estamos a tentar imitar mas como fazer
esta velhinha que tentou fazer restaurar
a caixa deveria na categoria a pintura
só que é o que ela faz o que ela fez é
removível nem consegue um bom
restaurante e consegue ter ali aquela
camada 30 e volta a partir da pintura
original
nós não conseguimos nós não conseguimos
porque temos mandato de paulo e esther
comprava vezes em a demanda estava podre
fosse uma prótese vinha aí tem que
tratar com tália contaria dourada das
igrejas têm que ser um restauro de um
artista
bom a história que tem muitos problemas
de facto há para além desses que eu tô
aqui falar também tem é atualmente essa
coisa né
algumas tecnologias muito pequenina
estamos temos que pôr tudo em 2006
parece que não é mais não há famílias
querem morar para o centro da cidade e
depois quando hebe foi embora e vamos
ficar só com de zeros
depois é outra coisa que é chávez há
ideias desaparecem as farmácias
drogarias retrosarias e só restaurantes
e lojas de suvenir
olha aqui mais uma vez fica difícil no
largo de são domingos havia uma maioria
que puxou agora é esta coisa do
apartamentos turísticos e restaurantes
aqui não no muro dos bacalhoeiros com a
crise mas pode passar sem ter a sensação
que estamos a entrar dentro de uma sala
de jantar é por que estamos a passar num
corredor no meio das pessoas a primeira
no ar diz lojas esta farmácia é agora é
uma loja de surfe unidos é mesmo
nem sei só como farmácia no centro agora
depois é esse barulho permanente que
acertamos
não é suposto os fluidos não 200
associados não é barulho de ruído obras
eu tenho dito que o centro histórico é
só tt é troca de turistas
não é todo o terreno
vejam isto é as quatro frentes de
gestante história do porto tenham 20 mil
habitantes nos nos 181 agora tem nós tem
menos que 5 mil são algumas projeções
tanto facto falta falta gente quanta
gente é o maior problema meu ver a
tensão é preciso trazer gente nós já não
estamos a caminho de conseguir fazer
isso
já a factos gente que está preocupada é
aí que tem feito alguma coisa
e mais uma vez chama atenção para a
cidade a condicionar e não você não
quiser nós não podemos deixar acontecer
tudo e deixar o mercado
vamos condicionar a crer que há um
congestionamento desafios desafio por
times do facto é é manutenção eu acho
que nós temos que conservar as coisas em
vez de tanta intrusão temos que
conservar e temos que fazer algumas
obras coercivas a obra conhecida o que é
quando o proprietário não tem mais não
consegue fazer a entidade que tutela o
território que a câmara municipal vai
fazer a obra faz nova mínima de
conservação em todos nós nesses oito
outras minhas sugestões é realmente
haver 11 transporte coletivo em que
funcione bem porque só tomavam já
circulam da peça escala e o ruído como
já vimos
portanto evitar os problemas destes
senhores que continuam a pintar as
janelas e ainda a gente faz isto o facto
é um processo difícil é preciso raspar
tudo pro primários para o esmalte mas
valeu a pena
o tráfego também alguns bons exemplos de
roswell moto que usava pela escola
superior artística do porto é um hotel
um hotel que fez uma obra interessante
também na rua são joão e rua do infante
o optaram por manter a carteirinha
antiga e terão outro problema que tem
uma função
já o cisa também usou né na recuperação
do schiavo e essa opção tem melhores
resultados térmicos e acústicos é o
restaurante dom antonio está fechado
neste momento que é uma é uma pena não
sei se vai abrir 11 no local na rua de
belo monte que tem que manter tamanha
janelas e conseguiu conservar o ambiente
e em dar algumas pessoas a laborar temos
vivemos há roupas caras ou passar uma
crítica do porto a nossa cultura também
ea ecológico e portanto o facto quando
tiveram as janelas com suas vidraças
tentamos tentar manter esta é a quinta
cidade a oportunidade que eu falo é essa
autenticidade e proteger essa
diversidade toda que existo
agora todas as pessoas não sei como é
que vai ser é um grande grande desafio
porque as pessoas foram embora e
migraram há muito tempo outros para maya
para matosinhos para gaia como é que o
que vamos trazer as pessoas de volta
pois é um a um até quatro as pessoas
morarem
ou então acaba aqui com esta minha
experiência em bristol facto quando eu
estive lá em 2010 a trabalhar na câmara
de bristol
aprendi muito e sobretudo sobre
cidadania formas de exercer a cidadania
é sobre democracia e sobre transparência
do processo
foram grandes lições e lá toda a gente
se envolve nessas instituições nem eu
nem minha no trabalho era falar com o
nome de grupo se conseguisse sites e
toda a gente queria ter uma parte da
decisão e em facto vale a pena você
desenvolver essa é minha mensagem aqui
hoje esta é vale a pena envolver em
cinéma decisão vale apenas juntar em
suma a seleção local fez o patrimônio
alcançar nosso próprio projeto para
salvar aquela rua que tal ao fim da
daquela casa ao fim da rua
abandonada e poderá precisar é do mundo
uma uma ajuda e tanto é esta é a
mensagem vamos lá nós a obra
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]